Let's now deal with manib stone licking
pagan faruk. This is stuff you already
know. But again, let me repeat like a
broken record. I get sick of repeating
myself. But I know myself. I know
humanity.
God designed us to learn by wrote by
repetition. Everything you knew in life
is repetition. When you were a child,
you were taught the alphabets
repetitively until it became second
nature and you can recall them
instinctively. Same thing with math.
Same thing in in any endeavor. For
example, in martial arts, what do
martial arts instructors have you do?
Boxing, kickboxing. They have you
perform [clears throat]
the same set of punches,
right? the same set of head movements,
the same set of kicks over and over and
over again. Or if you're a bodybuilder
like me, I build this body, baby, right?
Like me. I'm not a body. I'm just
kidding. Anyway, what do you do? You go
and perform the same set of exercises
for a certain number of repetitions.
Bench presses. Anyway, what's the point?
Even though you've heard something, you
need to hear that same thing over and
over again until it becomes second
nature by the grace of God. And another
thing about hearing something
repetitively, though you already know
it, the more you meditate, the more you
recall information,
the greater your understanding and
insight will be.
Right? Has it ever happened to you guys?
You read a Bible verse for years and
then let's say five years later light
switch went on and now you see something
in that verse you didn't see the
previous five years of reading it. See
that's how it works.
That's how it works. God designed you to
repeat something over and over again.
Repetitively praying, repetitively
singing praises, repetitively fasting,
repetitively meditating over God's word,
the Holy Bible. because that's how
you've been designed to learn and to go
much more deeper and discover
[clears throat] greater insights. So it
doesn't hurt to hear something over and
over again. But the thing is most of
these answers already archived.
We already have them archived sessions,
articles. So there are times in which I
don't need to repeat something. All you
need to do is go and rewatch, rehear, or
reread. And that's what I do. So, let's
begin. Okay, here's the clip.
Let's play it. Here's the clip again.
It's from Ask a Muslim. Is Jesus
Godmanuk?
And it's only 2 minutes and 45 seconds,
but we're going to have a meat fest.
>> Is Jesus God?
A very important question is is Jesus
God? And and you'll find a lot of
Christians tell you Jesus is God. But
let's go back to the Bible itself, the
the Old Testament and the New Testament.
If we take the Bible itself,
>> good remember he's inviting you to go to
the Holy Bible, God's word, and prove
your case from the Bible, right?
Remember, he's inviting you to do that.
Therefore, if I quote the Bible to
destroy Muhammad and the Quran, he can't
tell me the Bible's corrupt anymore,
right? Because he's telling you, let's
go to the Bible. Can't have your cake
and eat it, too. So, keep that in mind.
Use their words to because Jesus said,
"By your words, you shall be judged or
by your words you shall be acquitted."
Matthew 12:36-37.
>> Nowhere in the entire Bible does Jesus
ever come out and say that he is God.
For example, you will find words like
Yahweh, Elo, Jehovah in the Bible. But
Jesus will never come and say that I am
God ever in the entire Bible. And we
challenge Christians who are watching
this video to post. Let us know where
did Jesus ever say that. You may find
references to
>> Okay, just looking at his face, you can
see he's a disgusting, despicable
piece of like his prophet. Disgusting.
He looks and dirty. May the Lord give
him what he deserves. Okay, let's answer
that canard that we've answered five
million times. The assumption, what's
the assumption?
You must show me in those exact words,
which is something that Ahmedat made
popular. You must show me in those exact
words that Jesus said, I am God. Or
where he says in those exact words,
worship me. Now, I didn't finish the
post yet. I was going to gather material
for a short post that goes with this
session to make it easier for you to
address this argument because if you go
to the blog and answering Islam.info I
have I think 300 articles now I haven't
counted I think we I have 300 articles
rebuttals and they're scattered on my
own pages on answering Islam.info info
but also in the plyic rebuttal section
and on my blog you have to do a search
for a specific topic because I don't
have an index so it becomes hard for
people to find the answers okay it's
hard for people to find the answers
so what I try to do is I try to then
collect the best points and arguments
that are found throughout my articles
rebuttals and
collect them in one post as the Holy
Spirit loosens my tongue and saves me
from samuring. So the assumption Jesus
must say I am God or must say worship me
for a Muslim to accept those claims. Now
let's hold the Muslim accountable and
let's make sure the Muslim will be
consistent with his own criterion.
Okay, his own criterion. Are you ready?
So the assumption is Jesus must say it
in order for it to be true. If he
doesn't say it, it can't be true. So
this will all be in my post. Here's my
challenge. Show me in your Quran. You
guys know the challenges. You guys can
even do it on your own. But keep in mind
there are newbies that don't know this.
So they're hearing it for the first
time. Show me from your Quran where Asa
you believe the Quran records the actual
speeches,
events and the lives [clears throat] of
these prophets. So Isaiam Jesus son of
Mary you believe is the real Jesus. Show
me in your Quran where your Jesus, your
Isa says guys remember the challenge. I
am the Messiah El Messiah.
Show me in your Quran where Isa Jesus
says, "I am a word from Allah."
Show me in your Quran where Jesus says,
"I am the word of Allah which he cast
down to Mary." [clears throat]
Show me where he says, "I am a spirit
from Allah."
Allah.
Show me where Jesus says any of those
things in those words. You're Jesus.
Further, show me where Muhammad in your
Quran says, "I am a or I am the prophet
of Allah."
I want you to show me where your fake
prophet in your fake Quran says, "I am
Nebi Allah. I am the Nebi, the prophet
of Allah." Don't waste your time. You
can't find it. It's not there.
It's not there.
So, guess what he's going to tell you?
Guess what he's going to tell you?
Well, we don't need to have Jesus say
those things because we believe the
Quran. No, pure intensity. Not
listening, brother. Pure intensity. I'm
I'm You're not listening. But that's
okay. I'll help you out. We don't need
Jesus to say it because the Quran is a
speech of Allah and since Allah tells us
Jesus is
from him
his word which he cast down to Mary. I'm
not trying to impress you by saying the
Arabic
spirit from him and that he's the
Messiah. Since Allah in the Quran says
that about Jesus, that's good enough for
us.
So notice they're going to abandon their
criterion. They're going to say, "We
don't need Jesus to say it. If God says
it, that suffices." And if you ask,
"Well, where did God say it?" In the
Quran. And by the way, all these
statements about Jesus of the Quran are
found in the Quran. The Quran does say
he is a word from Allah. He is the word
of Allah. His word, the word of him,
which he cast down to Mary. And he is a
spirit from Allah. Spirit from him. Let
me give you the verses. Chapter 3 verse
45 of the Quran.
[clears throat] Chapter 4 verse 171.
So then you turn it against them.
Then you turn it against them. say, "All
right, since you believe the Quran is
the speech of God,"
and you take what God says as sufficient
proof of who Jesus is without requiring
Jesus to say it, well, by the same
token, you can't then use a different
criterion against me because I believe
my Bible is the inspired word of God.
inspired by God by sending the Holy
Spirit to raise up holy men whom the
Holy Spirit moved to record the words of
God through their own human language and
unique human personalities. But the
things they wrote though using human
language to communicate it are the words
of God communicated through human
language. Therefore, I don't need to
show you Jesus saying he's God. Because
if the Bible, God's word, tells me he's
God, THAT'S GOD HIMSELF saying Jesus is
God.